tras la toma del poder por el grupo
talibán numerosos países e instituciones
incluidos eeuu la unión europea y el
fondo monetario internacional se
apresuraron a bloquear fondos para
afganistán pero la onu aunque se muestra
crítica con el nuevo gobierno llamó a
permitir que el dinero siga fluyendo al
país para evitar una crisis humanitaria
de fans el propósito comprensible es
negar estos fondos de la administración
talibán de facto sin embargo el efecto
inevitable será una grave recesión
económica que podría arrojar a muchos
más millones a la pobreza y el hambre
ley moore millions interponer en hunger
la onu insistió en que aislar totalmente
al país no hará más que perjudicar a una
población que ya vive en una situación
extremadamente difícil y es que con un
gobierno aparentemente lejos de las
preocupaciones de los afganos y la
violenta represión a las manifestaciones
en kabul y otras ciudades el grupo
talibán debe ahora conquistar la
confianza del pueblo
sentir está despejado la gente pudiera
trabajar algunas personas dicen que
torturamos a la gente y que nos llevamos
a las mujeres ya las niñas yo digo que
eso no es cierto
pero en el valle de panchir la última
parte de afganistán donde los talibanes
reivindicaron el lunes su victoria el
objetivo es el mismo
tenemos un mensaje para nuestra nación
que siempre estamos a su servicio le
servimos los protegemos y los
proporcionamos seguridad
después de haber tomado militarmente el
país el grupo talibán se enfrenta ahora
al reto de gobernar afganistán en medio
del colapso de los servicios públicos y
del hundimiento de la economía por la
retirada de las tropas extranjeras